one of the pallbearers at senator
McCain's funeral on Saturday will be
mark Salter the Senators longtime aide
confidant and former chief of staff
the two men collaborated on seven books
many published by Simon & Schuster a
division of CBS marks ultras with us
from Phoenix good morning mark you
traveled on e John all over the world
with Senator McCain in strange places
small places why did the senator feel
like he had to throw himself across the
globe all the time well I think he he
was intent on on helping American
leadership in the world and extending
America's values to places where they
didn't exist
most trip she talked about never
included Paris or Rome or places you
might want to take yourself but we were
we were in Burma many times and
vientianne in places where he thought he
could do something good you wrote a lot
of speeches for the senator in addition
to the books which was easier writing a
speech in which John McCain was winning
something or in which he had been
defeated the latter I mean we were
talking about some of those speeches the
other day because he would never let us
write them for him or with him until we
knew what was going to happen in an
election and I guess the the
hehe had a lot of he won a lot of
Elections he lost two big ones obviously
the presidential elections in 2000 and
2008 but I always thought he was I had a
line in something I wrote the other day
that said he was defiant and defeat and
sometimes in victory too and it's a more
attractive quality and defeat I think
but he tried to stand up and he was very
magnanimous all the time too and I
always thought he just looked and acted
and spoke his best you know when he had
suffered a personal defeat but still
felt optimistic and hopeful about about
the country you collaborated as John
mentioned with McCain on so many of his
writings did you work with him on that
final letter and how close to his death
did he write it and it sounds like he
wanted to send a message he did we
worked on it and I think I was out here
in the early spring mark March timeframe
working on the book the last book
together and he mentioned to me that he
wanted to he wanted to have a statement
released after he had passed away and
along the lines of his concession speech
in 2008 actually a big part of that was
taken from there and so we put together
something for him and he looked at it
and he suggested a few edits here and
there and read it a few times said okay
put it in a drawer and that's that's
that's what we did the tone and the
words in this letter make it sound like
he almost anticipated how President
Trump would react to his death I'm
specifically referring to that line we
weaken our greatness when we confuse our
patriotism with tribal rivalries do you
think that's the case well I don't think
he anticipated what President Trump
would be doing the days after his death
no I think he I think he had made that
argument already in the fall he wanted
to address the kind of nativism that
that seemed a pop you know populism that
that was becoming nativism I you know
you know that he had argued against
before so mark I can see if this is very
painful for you he was such a class act
and I think a lot of us are now paying a
lot more attention to John McCain
looking at him differently reading about
him hearing about things we didn't hear
before what an amazing man and what an
honor for you to have gotten to know him
the way that you did the honor of a
lifetime yeah I feel that I met him in
New Orleans in 1988 and sort of
accidentally and it was the luckiest day
of my life yeah thank you very much Mark
Salter for joining us this morning
thanks thanks for having me thank you
Mark thinking of you